bonjour à toutes et à tous ceux c'est
paléo news l'émission qui fait des news
avec du vieux alors ça y est le projet
trine axe c'est fini on a emmené cédric
jurassique sur le terrain et je vous
montre en ce moment une des nombreuses
vidéos qu'il a fait il en a fait 13 ans
tous vous pouvez les retrouver dans la
description alors j'ai essayé de tout
les retrouver mais le fait est qu'il les
a placés en ont répertorié juste avant
que je commence à faire cette vidéo
juste avant que je fasse le paléo news
donc j'ai pas pu récupérer les liens de
tous et vlog donc il faudra aller le
harceler sur sa chaîne pour qu'il les
remette en ligne ou qu'ils partagent le
lien mais voilà on a emmené cédric
jurassique sur le terrain ça s'est très
bien passé on a ramené beaucoup beaucoup
de fossiles on a catalogué 151 fossiles
ça veut pas dire qu'on les a tous ramené
ça veut dire qu'on a trouvé 151 fossiles
certains on a préféré les laisser sur
place soit pour faire du palais au
tourisme donc pour développer le
tourisme local basé sur les fossiles
soit parce qu'ils étaient plutôt
intéressant du point de vue taffonneau
milk et on a aussi ramené on a on a
aussi découvert des choses nouvelles
donc des potentiellement des espèces
nouvelles en tout cas des choses qui
vont un petit peu inchangé 2
le les connaissances actuelles quoi et
notamment la découverte de deux sino
dont tu 1 du permien et un du trias
celui du trias il est particulièrement
complet d'ailleurs c'est celui que je
vais vous montrer là sur cette vidéo de
cédric jurassique que je sais que je
suis en train de montrer à l'écran en ce
moment donc y en a un qui vient du trias
l'autre qui vient du permien est celui
du permien a de fortes chances d'être
probablement le plus ancien silo dont tu
donc les sino d'onde c'est la famille de
reptiles malien donc de deux prêts
malien devrais je dire qui a donné
naissance aux mammifères donc voilà un
exemple de sinnoh d'onde du trias à
l'écran qui apparaît et donc nous on a
trouvé c'est l'équivalent de ce truc là
mais dans le permien et qui serait
probablement le plus ancien donc on va
on va l'étudier un ça va prendre du
temps ça va prendre beaucoup de temps
probablement plusieurs années ça va
ça il va y avoir besoin de beaucoup de
monde pour travailler dessus mais voilà
et là cédric est très fière de vous
montrer le fossile qu'il a trouvé un
fossile de liste rose or donc un indice
hinault donc du permien le fameux d'ici
no doubt qui a survécu à la crise
permien trias donc voilà je vous suggère
très fortement si vous voulez en savoir
plus sur tout ce qui s'est passé durant
ce projet trine axe d'aller voir les
vidéos de cédric que je mets en
descriptions d'aller sur l'instar g le
twitter et de facebook de cédric je
doute quand même qu'il y ait des gens
qui sont abonnés à ma chaîne qui ne
connaissent pas c'est vrai que jurassic
quand même ça ça me paraît un peu
bizarre mais s'il y en a bien les y
aller découvrir cédric jurassique il a
une lahina point démérité
voilà il est quand même venu
il est quand même venu en afrique du sud
il il en a chié
voilà c'était pas des vacances que les
choses soient claires il a bien bossé et
il va nous préparer une vidéo donc là il
a fait développe pour l'instant il a
fait 13 blog mais il va nous préparer
une vidéo
avec montage etc il va préparer il a
préparé des interviews il a préparé
plein de choses donc voilà allez vous
abonner à la chaîne de sévery jurassique
si vous ne vous n'êtes pas déjà abonnés
parce qu'il va se passer des choses si
vous voulez en savoir plus sur le projet
trine axe
voilà je moi personnellement je pense
pas que je vais poster havelock sur le
projet trine axe à moins que justement
il y ait des développements dans le
futur qui qui permette enfin quelques
cédric forcément ne pourra pas montré
sur sa chaîne puisque les développements
maintenant il est rentré en france voilà
donc il pourra pas montrer les
développements futurs mais si il y à des
développements futurs
à propos du projet et que je peux vous
en parler je vous en parlerai mais je ne
pense pas pouvoir faire mieux que cédric
jurassique pour ce qui est des choses
qu'il a déjà pu filmer quoi donc voilà
allez voir sa chaîne si vous voulez en
savoir plus sur le projet trine axe
aussi j'en profite si vous êtes
intéressé par le projet trina que c'est
bien il ya un article qui vient de
sortir dans la revue fossiles qui est
normalement disponible en kiosque mais
que vous pouvez aussi commander sur ce
lien donc je le mettrais dans la
description voilà dans la revue fossiles
on a écrit un article sur les thérapies
des autres fossiles du caroux donc on
explique exactement presque étape par
étape le le voyage qu'on a fait avec
cédric jurassique à travers le permien
et puis à travers le trias puis jusqu au
jurassique avec les empreintes de
dinosaures
à la frontière du lesotho donc voilà si
vous voulez en savoir plus aussi à
propos du projet trine axe vous pouvez
lire cet article
il n'est pas directement à propos du
projet trine axe mais c'est exactement
le il décrit exactement la démarche
qu'on a suivi le trajet qu'on a suivi
pendant le projet trine axe donc c'est
la même philosophie quoi si vous voulez
et puis si de manière générale vous
voulez en savoir plus pour le sur le à
propos du travail qu'on fait en afrique
du sud
ben voilà c'est c'est dans cet article
et en plus on est très content parce que
notre article sur la couverture voilà
donc maintenant dans l'actualité
paléontologique et bien évidemment vous
n'avez pas pu passer à côté de ce petit
chiot de 18 mille ans découvert dans le
pergélisol syberia donc découvert
congelé magnifiquement préservé puisque
vous pouvez voir il est il est quasiment
entiers alors le dos voiliers a perdu sa
fourrure il aa peut décomposer mais
sinon pour le reste il est très très
bien préservés et alors j'appelle ça un
chiot parce que les scientifiques qui
sont en train de l'étudier appelle ça un
chiot alors j'ai tendance à me méfier de
ces annonces quand on trouve des
nouveaux fossiles dans le pergélisol
parce qu'ils ont tendance à les faire
avant d'avoir pu étudier les animaux
dont vous aviez par exemple les normes
lula la grosse tête de loup du
pléistocène qui a été découverte plus
tôt cette année donc il ya eu la tête de
loup géante du pléistocène et je n'en
avais pas fait un paléo news parce que
justement bas ils en ont parlé sans même
sans même prendre le temps de l'étudier
encore donc il savait même pas quelle
espèce c'était sachant que les loups
géant normalement dans le pléistocène de
sibérie en a pas il ya des espèces de
loups mais elles sont pas censés être
gigantesque là on était sur une tête de
loup absolument énorme je crois deux
fois la taille d'un d'un loup d'un loup
moderne quoi donc bon sachant que ça
n'avait pas encore été publiés
dans une revue à comité de lecture je
m'étais méfier du coup je l'avais pas
trop relayé cette information donc en
ayant peur que ce soit en fait une sa
phase plof donc voilà mais celle là je
la relaye parce qu'en lisant l'article
en fait je me rends compte qu'ils ont
déjà fait les analyses génétiques ils
ont déjà fait les datations au carbone
14 donc apparemment ils ont bonne idée
quand même de ce qui se passe cet
étrange qu'ils en parlent avant d'avoir
publié dans une revue à comité de
lecture mais parce que généralement ces
revues elles ont un embargo un système
d'embargo et que du coup du coup on
n'est pas censé faire des communiqués de
presse avant d'avoir publié mais bon bah
voilà deux villes l'ont fait quand même
donc et puis tant mieux j'ai envie de
dire mais en tout cas ouais c'est une
très très belle découverte parce que si
si l'adn de ce truc de ce truc là
correspond effectivement plus à l'adn
d'un chien cas l'adn rou bat ça ça
voudrait dire que le il y avait déjà des
chiens il ya dix huit mille ans ce qui
tendrait à confirmer une origine plutôt
ancien des chiens parce qu'il ya deux
théories qui s'affrontent à la théorie
qui dit que les chiens
ont été domestiqués il ya entre 10 et 13
milan et il ya la théorie qui dit que
les chiens ont été domestiqués bien
avant ça il ya entre 30 et 40 mille ans
donc enfin les loups ont été domestiqués
un chien évidemment c'est ça que je veux
dire il ya entre 30 et 40 mille ans donc
et lab pour le coup avec dix-huit mille
ans si on a déjà une différenciation au
niveau des gènes il ya dix-huit mille
ans et que le loup a été domestiqué bien
avant ça donc donc là on aurait une
découverte qui irait vers une
domestication très ancienne du loup
ancien et en plus on aurait une très
très belle un très bel exemple
d'anatomie préserver il ya notamment les
dents à regarder regardez ces ses
incisives magnifique alors il ya
plusieurs personnes qui m'ont demandé si
des incisives comme ça c'était
spécifique des chiens ou si ça se
trouvait aussi chez les loups ça se
trouve aussi chez les loups voilà et là
en l'occurrence l'anatomie enfin le la
morphologie à 3 q speed des incisives et
d'autant plus proéminente qu'il s'agit
n'a juvénile donc les dents sont pas
encore usées
mais voilà ça se retrouve aussi chez les
loups donc c'est pas ça qui fait de cet
animal 1
un loup un chien plutôt qu'un loup c'est
vraiment les analyses génétiques mais on
attend quand même la publication des
résultats définitifs dans une revue à
comité de lecture afin de sauter au
plafond
en tout cas c'est une très très belle
découverte quoi qu'il arrive justement
puisqu'on parle de paléogénétique
passons maintenant à gigan topic accuse
donc dont une étude a été récemment
publiée voyez 13 novembre 2019 et cette
étude s'intéresse aux protéines
préserver dans les mailles de dés dans
de gigantesques et et cus gigantomachie
tqs qui est donc le grand singe géant
qui nous vient de d'asie et qui est qui
pour le coup donc ses dents ont donné
des protéines et ses protéines ont pu
être séquencés et analyser comparer aux
protéines des des grands singes actuels
donc gorille homo sapiens les chimpanzés
et gigan topi tech
il se trouve qu'ils tombent plus près d
des ponts giné c'est à dire des orangs
outans que d autres grands singes donc
ce qui confirme ce qu'on avait déjà vue
à partir de la morphologie c'est à dire
que gigan topi tech et un une sorte de
d'orangs outans géant voilà là ne la
news suivante c'est la découverte c'est
la découverte d'une preuve de
pollinisation dans des fleurs du crétacé
donc dans delambre birman datant d'il ya
100 millions d'années
d des paléontologues ont découvert un
petit insecte et aux pattes de cet
insecte et bien il y à du pollen du
pollen qui étaient accrochés aux pattes
dans ce qui veut dire que cet insecte
transporter du pollen dans le poil de
ses pattes donc ce qui veut dire déjà
qu'ils avaient du pollen dont il y avait
des plantes à fleurs bon pas une grosse
surprise au crétacé mais ça veut surtout
dire et bien que cet insecte était
était finalement transmettait ces grains
de pollen d'une fleur à l'autre et vous
voyez indiqué par des petites flèches
bleues les structures qui servent aux
pollens à s'accrocher aussi sur les
pattes de l'insecte donc les pollens et
est aussi adapté à être transportés par
des insectes et ça c'est quand même
super cool c'est super cool d'autant
plus que là pour le coup c'est du très
très beau fossiles vous voyez que la fin
normalement les fossiles dans l'ombre
c'est juste les empreintes des insectes
donc c'est une bulle en fait en forme de
l'insecte qui est qui se trouve à
l'intérieur mais là vous voyez qu'il ya
quand même des différences de textures
qui indique qu'il a dit quand même une
préservation tout à fait exceptionnel
donc c'est vraiment du très très beau
fossiles et ça confirme finalement ce
dont on se doutait déjà
c'est à dire que les insectes étaient
capables de polliniser que finalement
les plantes à fleurs et les uns et les
insectes pollinisateurs ont probablement
évoluer ensemble
enfin dernières news et j'ai presque
envie de dire que j'ai envie de terminer
sur un coup de gueule parce que ça c'est
quelque chose qui m'a un petit peu ouah
ça m'a un petit peu secoué quand je les
lui donc c'est là la publication d'une
nouvelle espèce de ptérosaure qui a pris
le nom de tard car yens draco donc tag
tard gharyane draco qui signifie le
dragon des targaryen évidemment en
référence à game of thrones est en fait
en voyant qu'ils avaient nommé cette
nouvelle espèce targaryen de draco je me
suis dit tu vas voir que c'est encore un
rogatons tout dégueulasse que c'est un
fossile qui est pas beau du tout et en
lisant la publication jeu
je dois avouer que j'ai pas été trop
déçu parce que voilà il ya un bout de
mâchoire yassa et il ya ça voilà et
générique de fin voila voila et je
trouve ça un peu je trouve ça un peu
dommage je suis le premier à me réjouir
quand on fait des références à la
culture pop notamment quand il s'agit de
de nommer des trucs à partir des dragons
voilà je suis le premier à me réjouir qu
en face des références à la culture pop
canton quand on nomme des nouvelles
espèces
mais quand ça sert juste à camoufler le
fait que c'est que c'est des restes pas
super bien préservés et pour franchement
intéressant ça me chagrine
quand même ça me chagrine ce que la
logique derrière ça elle est toute
simple assez qu'on veut faire un
communiqué de presse à partir d'un d'un
fossile qui est pas au bout du tout
comme le fossile n'est pas au bout du
tout vous vous intéresserez jamais la
presse sauf si bas sauf si vous lui
donnez un nom un peu clinquant
voilà donc voulu donner un nom qui
termine par draco qui veut dire dragon
parce que c'est un ami et parce que
c'est un reptile volant
et puis vous rajoutez tard gardienne de
vent pour que ça fasse pour que ça
appelle une référence de la pop culture
bon voilà c'est ça s'était vu aussi
voilà thanos ce dinosaure qui n'était
connu que par une seule vertèbres voilà
pourquoi pourquoi ils l'ont rappelé
thanos bas pour pouvoir faire un
communiqué de presse évidemment sinon
personne ne se serait intéressé à cette
seule vertèbres qu'est-ce qu'il ya eu
d'autres il ya eu ce rhône iops il ya
déjà quelques années donc le l'oeil de
sauron à l'oeil de sauron qui n'était
jamais qu'un petit fragment de crâne un
minuscule fragment de crâne et c'est
tout quoi donc ils ont nommé une
nouvelle espèce
à propos de ça et pourquoi il nomme une
nouvelle espèce juste avec un tout petit
fragment de crâne bas pour faire un
communiqué de presse en l'appelant se
renie obs quoi donc
c'est triste mais c'est le reflet exact
de la recherche paléontologique
aujourd'hui de l'état de la recherche
paléontologique aujourd'hui si vous
voulez des fonds il faut promettre des
communiqués de presse
et si vous voulez garantir un communiqué
de presse et bains vous nommer une
nouvelle espèce à partir d'un événement
de la pop culture
voilà et comme ça quel que soit le
fossile que vous avez découvert et ben
il aura un nom en référence à la pop
culture et vous pouvez vous pourrez le
vendre aux médias
voilà donc c'est très triste c1 c'est un
symptôme du fait qu'il ya plus de thunes
voilà dans la recherche paléontologique
voilà ça donc c'est pour ça que je mets
ça dans la catégorie coup de gueule
parce que c'est c'est à la fois c'est à
la fois sympa de le voir sortir comme ça
d'un devoir pop et dans l'est dans vos
fils d'actualité et sur les réseaux
sociaux de voir pop et des nouvelles
espèces qui portent des noms super
marrant et mais en même temps le fait
qu'il y ait de plus en plus d'espèces
avec des noms super marrant bas c'est le
symptôme qu'il n'y a plus une thune et
que du coup on peut il faut absolument
sûr vendre des choses et que c'est le
moyen le plus simple de survendre les
choses de leur fils et des noms marrants
donc bon voilà je j'espère que ça nous
arrivera pas en tout cas pour le projet
trine axe c'est sûr on a trouvé des
jolies choses donc même si on leur donne
des noms marrants ce sera pas survendu
voilà donc merci à tous d'avoir suivi ce
paléo news je vous dis à très bientôt et
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner pour ne
rien manquer d'anciens salut
[Musique]